but we've got some um uh my friends luke
is about to
explode you're watching his head explode
in real time i'm ready
the most egregious act of censorship
is quite possibly what's what's the
opposite of irony
like the epitome you know like it would
be like ironic if a fire truck's on fire
but what is it actually maybe it is kind
of ironic
ron paul getting censored on facebook
well okay the libertarian guy getting
censored
okay but i was getting opinions here i
was going no no no no
no i was i was going to mention it's
like you were like well why ron paul i
mean
why right well he's
do you remember who he endorsed for uh
the democratic candidate
for president ooh tulsi gabbard oh
boom that's right that's the problem
that's the problem that
like of all the democrats to endorse
not her not the black sheep forget it
well this is the thing that's really
surprising here when you look at ron
paul he obviously his career is based on
calling out violations of people's
personal liberty
uh violations of government's abuse of
power he's a staunch
anti-war activist he he pretty much is
the main guy who calls for peace in the
middle east
but yet now he's being jumped lumped in
as as
this kind of trump uh whitewashing this
kind of
trump censorship effort that's happening
here and i'm having a lot of people
respond to this saying good get rid of
his
hate speech and i'm like what he's
calling for peace in the middle east
what kind of hate speech are you talking
about he's talking about personal
responsibility
and individual liberty how is that
labeled as
hate speech and this is the response by
blue checkmark people and i'm like okay
okay
give me an example of this because
that's a very ignorant statement since
of course
it was ron paul that criticized donald
trump on many of his foreign policy
adventures
and then i was called how dare you call
a woman ignorant this is the
there's there's the reply thing that's
going on in my twitter
called a woman ignorant no i said her
mother
that was her response and i'm like look
i don't care what kind of junk you have
between your legs
give me an example of of how ron paul
hates speech her opinion is
automatically and i love yours and then
she called me a misogynist and i'm like
what does that have to do with anything
i don't care what thing you have between
your legs what matters here is is your
bigger allegation here and people are
jumping in
and even coming after me and people are
forgetting i criticized donald trump
like all the time and and now people are
lumping me in into this because i'm
standing up for ron paul who shouldn't
be lumped into this in the first place
so let me let me let me read the quote
from from ron paul
he said with no explanation other than
repeatedly going against our community
standards
facebook has blocked me from managing my
page
never have we received notice of
violating community standards in the
past and nowhere
in the offending post identified you
know you know what's funny about this
you know you listen you know what you'll
hear if you you turn on like ron paul
and the fed the gold standard sound
currencies
freedom liberty no wars it's not even
in like the things that ron paul's been
famous for and the things he talks about
for the most part his like
key focus isn't even a part of the
mainstream culture war
for the most part there's only one other
person i know of who constantly talks
about ending the federal
reserve and he's sitting in this room
right in front of me hello
oh ian's here yeah i got it from
williams he sure did yeah
ian's been very quiet tonight but people
are celebrating this as some kind of
cultural victory
against hate speech and i'm like what
are you talking about
about white supremacists about domestic
terrorism i'm like
you know the blue check marks are
bringing this up right now this woke mob
is bringing this up
and and again conflating so many
important issues as
as i'm as i keep saying policies don't
matter power matters
and these people are power hungry and
going after individuals like ron paul
absolutely proves it to an objective
viewer who's just walking into this
situation who really wants to understand
maybe but you know look we're all uh old
people so you've got these 20-somethings
you know because there's one thing i
really i started to realize
when we had some of these younger lefty
guests on the show they were
you know when ron paul was coming into
prominence is like 12 years ago
now the big ron paul era the ron paul
love revolution
so i'm you know we're all old enough to
have remembered that but these kids were
like 10.
you know now they're 22 and they're like
yay communism
and they don't know who ron paul is at
all other than he was like a republican
so they're like yay ban the old white
man
and it's like he's for freedom i don't
know or care get rid of him
that's it fox news and cnn was attacking
him nonstop when he was running to be
president of the united states he was
the only one
standing up as a principled individual
against
this crazy aggressive american foreign
policy against the military-industrial
complex against the actual issues that
literally mattered and now he's being
lumped in
into into maga and rand paul's dad
that's why
well again rand paul is not ron paul the
the two uh are very different they have
very different policies
uh ron paul made sure to always vote no
no matter what it was
so you got to give someone like that you
know respect he was in there
and and he sent out you know uh he
worked with kucinich
yeah he worked out with dennis he worked
with denis kucinich cynthia mckinney a
lot of the kind of old-school
anti-establishment representatives that
were
not just republican not just democrat
but individuals that stood on principles
do we have any of those left uh that's
the
would you would you give credit to rand
paul for that partly
i don't like any politicians as you know
not even ron paul
well we have one for a couple more days
and that would be tulsi gabbard
yeah you know i mean she endorsed biden
yeah she did
did she did she endorsed biden
because allegedly bernie was a meanie
and bernie is a meanie i i've been
around bernie
throughout the kind of presidential
debate circuit and
at public events he's a mean guy barney
yeah he's like he's
well didn't you see that that
documentary about him where he wouldn't
shake the woman's hand
and he wouldn't pop the shoulder back
into place and he didn't want to drink
the two percent milk
no i don't yeah you know you you don't
know what that is you guys know what
that is right mm-hmm
the asset cur burn your enthusiasm on
snow yeah one of one of the only
funny things centered live they've got
very few really funny things a lot of
their stuff is really dry but
they did that famous you know they had
um what's the guys
larry david yeah playing bernie sanders
and he's like he wouldn't shake the
lady's hand because she coughed in her
hand you remember that right
you've never seen it uh i mean i've seen
i've seen the larry david
stuff i don't remember that particularly
i don't watch saturday night live viral
bernie video is hilarious
so he's like he won't put uh the only
milk they have for his coffee is two
percent
and so he's like i want whole milk and
so he goes out and then like
a woman crashes her car on her way to
vote for him and she's like pop my
shoulder and please like i'm not gonna
do that and
he ends up losing by just that amount of
votes of the people he refused to help
and then like that's the joke he loses
by two percent but dumb
it was hilarious jerk burns allegedly
because of interpersonal drama between
bernie and tulsi this is one of the
reasons why tulsi decided
to endorse for joe biden and i think
also
i think she voted for him i don't know
well i don't
i don't know but i'll say i think tulsi
has tried
to prevent the fracturing and
hyperpolarization tried i'm not saying
successful but
in the in you know the last bit of her
remaining
you know congressional term she's put
out some fairly moderate
liberal type policies pertaining to
cultural issues but she's also
come you know uh out against
you know like the the russian
investigation ended and she's like
that's it
that's right it's done like like let's
move on that's why they don't like her
well she's
you know yeah she's she's a progressive
but she's not
she's not triggered she's not she's more
she's very
she's objective she has principles she
there there's things
that she will fight for and fight to
death for
but she's not she is not hyper partisan
and that's i would never she's vote for
her corporate establishment
but she's not hyper partisan and that's
why i like her that's why i respect her
how crazy is it
that tulsi gabbard who is she i'm
understanding she's for gun control
right it's like one of her one of her
positions yes
she's for increasing the minimum wage to
15 an hour
she opposes nuclear energy she is very
on the left
and they call her right wing they say
she was assigned republican at birth
and she goes on tucker carlson and she
goes on fox news
she is not on the right in any sense of
those words
but that's how insane the overton window
is right now people
even tulsi gabbard is right-wing people
only remember two things
about her uh she went to syria and met
with uh
al-assad yep right even though she had
permission to do it
right it's a callback joke to a joe
rogan episode but i don't think she's a
toady
but also the second thing was she
opposed gay marriage
and it's like yeah well so did joe biden
and so did barack obama
so did hillary clinton but because
again she's she's like the outcast of
the dnc because she was
she was vetted for the dnc they were
like this is going to be
one of the next big stars and then she
started questioning the establishment
she was like
well we had 24 debates between
hillary and obama and now in 2016 cycle
we're gonna have
six yeah really we're gonna have that's
it and she went after kamala
really hard yes
when tucker carlson mispronounced her
name they said it was racist yeah i'm
just trying to help you
and when and when joe i'd be a bigot and
when joe biden uh
pronounced her name improperly i mean
you know it was just chalk it up to old
man
he has a stutter or also also when he
said um
you know uh doug imhoff kamala's wife oh
my gosh
which uh you know i i i like that too i
mean that's the joke that everybody's
been making anyway
but you know it's still funny comeless
wife
joe biden oh man
well let's hope let's hope in two years
they the um
the republicans uh learned their lessons
from from the last no i'll tell you
what's going to happen in two years
so they did win in the house in the
state levels so which means they're
going to control
redistricting which will give them
massive advantages
in the next election that's a lot of
people don't realize isn't it isn't that
creepy
that it's not about your message it's
all just team
sports and because we went at the state
level now we're going to win at the
house level
and it's like ideas kind of are relevant
just
oppose the other i guess but it's also
the census
you know thanks to thanks to uh krovet
and all these terrible
terrible policies you have states like
texas and florida which actually might
gain a gain
a congressional district california
might lose one california might lose two
and same and the same thing with um with
new york
they were they were they were expected
to lose one they might lose
three total three which it's it's
possible but there was always to talk
about
uh how if they were at least gonna lose
one and this is before
you know the pandemic that that uh aoc's
district
would basically they would just
eliminate it and
swallow like basically swallow it up
between all the other districts
and then she would have to either run in
in another district
or just decide that she's gonna run for
senate which is going to happen
one of the biggest issues in the culture
war split right now is
trans issues you know you can see that
conservatives don't agree with the idea
of misgendering or they say there's only
two genders and the left clearly
disagrees
i i'm willing to bet that you give it
four maybe eight years and republicans
are gonna be 100
on board with all of it i'm not kidding
i'm not trying to you know be bombastic
or anything i think they'll be 100 on
both all of it completely
and the left will be much further in in
the direction of
some new kind of you know issue
pertaining to
love or sexuality or identity itself how
much further can they go though like oh
they where
where will they be eight years other can
well like trans species what about like
cutting off your limbs
yes already body dysmorphia but then
what happens with
uh say the tulsi gabbard uh legislation
that she
uh introduced to protect to protect yeah
so do you do you think and are you
saying also that in eight years
like where does where does that go what
happens
if we look historically back at how uh
culture has shifted is there a reason to
believe the right will retake ground in
the coming
eight years especially considering the
democrats just see like took every you
know every branch of the federal
government
it's possible because you can have
assuming they pack the supreme court not
only just that but also
influencing people through the
algorithms and the timelines and what
they've been
showing through social media
manipulation hollywood right right right
all the subliminal
listen listen listen you you go watch a
kid's show and see
the things that are that are in it these
kids are going to grow up and they're
going to vote
and they are going to be even further
culturally
you know progressive than 20 year olds
today
and you're going to get a bunch of i
tell you this is the funniest thing
these these lefties who are like 25
in 10 years they're going to be right
wing and then the new left is going to
be these kids they're having similar
conversations that that we had
and then we're going to find a lot of
these people now agreeing with us on
certain issues
but if you look what you got to do i'll
tell you something really creepy
i saw this post it was uh someone
tweeted at christopher ruffo
go on google and search for kids being
taught that they're white supremacists
take that same quote and put it in
duckduckgo and see the results
when you when you when you put it in
google it's like your kid is a white
supremacist how to teach your kid their
white supremacist you put it in
duckduckgo and it's
news about how schools are teaching this
so here's my prediction
i see no reason to believe the right is
going to make any cultural gains at all
they've never been in uh for whatever
reason
smart enough i guess or uh uh
understanding of
having an understanding of the game to
go after cultural institutions now the
daily wire is doing movies
and they have that new movie it's called
what's called run hide fight which looks
seriously intense
it looks like i've seen it is it good
it's solid it's solid it's
very intense and and after the the last
week or so uh with with everything going
on
it's very stressful
uh no it's gonna uh like i'm i'm not
being paid
by the daily word they sent me they sent
me a screener uh they sent lauren chen
a screen or two and and i was like uh
and i remembered i'm like i think i have
something in my inbox from their pr team
uh but it's it's a it's a solid movie as
thomas jane who yeah
the punisher it has treat williams who
is in uh the substitute movies
right you know so um this this this girl
i cannot remember her name
this girl is like like her real name oh
the actor's name yeah she
zoe hull is her character name but the
the actress who plays her is
badass she's she's really can we get
really good
can we get a screener and didn't the
punisher guy get cancelled because of
vocal culture as well
i don't think so maybe i don't know but
it's a it's a great it's a great
it's it's it's not like the greatest
movie you're ever going to see ben
shapiro is definitely hyping it up but
it is definitely it is definitely a
solid movie it's worth the watch
and what's your what's your what's your
score one out of 100 out of
oh god like uh like around tomato score
yeah like a 79
80. yeah it's not it's not the look
there is
i don't want to
the point i'm trying to make is this may
be one of the first times there is a
conservative production
from for a piece of content that's
actually worth watching
yeah it was definitely worth the watch
what's that super religious netflix they
have
got flicks is that what it's called i
think that's what it's called
you know what it is because it's like
it's on the fox
uh commercial like i see that commercial
on fox news all the time it's like
yeah but yeah well the productions oh
watches that stuff it always looks rash
it looks cheap it looks like okay like
veggie tails honey can you can
can you get the kids camcorder i want to
like shoot something yeah
you know run hide fight
it's it is uh stylish it looks good
camera works great it doesn't look cheap
right it doesn't feel cheap
there's actually there is a scene though
where one of the guys is holding a gun
and it's a rubber gun
and it's bending and i could not take my
eyes off of it couldn't they just get a
replica what are they doing well they
did they had some but
i guess they didn't have enough to go
around us i don't i don't know what
what it was production-wise but i just
see this this guy's he's holding
he's holding it and the barrel is like
like it's not just pointing down but
then it's pointing to the right and i'm
like oh my
come on you couldn't fix that like
there's your easter egg well
it was a screener it was a screener so
they'll probably digital no no
no they'll fix it no no it's not the
movie's done they can they can edit it
digitally what do you mean
they they it's a screener they don't
think it's not released yet
yeah they could of course uh you they
won't what if they didn't
tell them they'll like cgi a gun from
like fix it bad 64.
anyway the point is that does make me
think that there is a potential for
media to start being produced that will
influence a younger generation
but they're still 10 years out from
actually getting any foothold in culture
well now that everything's streaming
right uh
yeah because you know this is you know
when you when you get to playstation
or the new xbox there's always like the
killer game it's like the game you have
to have
right there's not a lot of content
coming out other than
you know what's on disney plus like i
don't that wanda vision looks just
bizarre weird and i've been no
interested in seeing that right
but i was so excited watching this that
the trailer is great for run
hide fight right and maybe
that like if there's something good like
the mandalorian
you know the mandalorians like it's kind
of like a must-see thing
right now if if if people are into that
kind of action movie and there are no
action moves out right now you know
because movie theaters are
pretty much dead and we can have that
conversation another time but yeah
uh but having something like the killer
app
you know of this movie you know to get
subs like
go for it now another thing i kind of
wanted to bring up and talk to you guys
about is when you dominate culture
you have a lot of power and control and
i think you could be right too but i
think also there could be a kind of
reaction towards this because
if you look at culture especially in the
united states especially in the 1990s
it hasn't changed or progressed since
usually the 80s had
had its own unique culture the 70s the
60s they had their own hair
their own clothes their own music their
own kind of way of life their own kind
of
uh environment and and excitement about
those times
since the 90s we don't have any of them
that's not true i mean in my opinion
i haven't seen a huge difference between
the 2000s the 2010s i don't see a change
in clothing i don't
see a change in hair i don't see a
change in music i see it all becoming
kind of repetitively the same or
i'm just becoming old you're probably
coming old okay so
you can look at the what are they called
the audies that's what they refer to as
the
the 2000s the audience and the 2010s and
there's distinct music that was popular
in the early 2000s that was prominent on
networks and on social platforms on
myspace and things like this
that aren't really that popular anymore
so each decade does still have its
shifting you know cultural trends and
everything like that
and maybe you just don't see it because
it's easy to look back at the 90s
and recognize that you know baggy
button-up shirt and like
i don't know stone-table pilots and
stuff like that the 80s were
weird everybody agrees yes 80s were
weird
what was it like leopard print hot pink
hot pants yeah what were they thinking
while they roller skated
but for me for me nothing not much has
changed uh
that's just my opinion maybe i'm just
seeing it a lot of people a lot of
things do
you know a lot of things are cyclical
like back in the 80s camouflage pants
were a big deal and you know
then to me it's like they're
regurgitating everything especially with
movies
oh well i mean fashion definitely is i
do think
oh by by the way isabelle may that's the
girl who plays
okay and it's pure flicks
you're great and and i hope that you're
you have a great future because
oh i don't know though she did a daily
wire movie oh yeah uh
yeah i heard ben shapiro was a fascist
so um
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that sounds like that sounds like
vengeance yeah that that
silly little hat it's all a ruse
how about how stupid you have to be to
think ben shapiro is all right it's the
most
insane thing ever he's
he's jewish he's a number one say to
that but also he's not
he's not cr like he's not edgy crazy
conservative
you know and what i like about very
mainstream what i like about ben
is that he he's you know he comes from a
has a law background right so that he
approaches
these things very differently than you
know most
uh pundits you know like mark levin you
know he's
he's all about you know constitutional
law so you see that
way but but ben but calling ben shapiro
radical which which
aoc has by the way called him
radical which is just mind-blowing like
this is how stupid she is
ben shapiro is so much more like
traditional conservative like a kind of
person
the kind of opinions we know and expect
and aoc is the radical with opinions
you'd be confused by
yeah and i i just mean like when aoc
comes in a lot of things she advocates
for you're kind of like
about what like what is like bench pro
comes in you're like oh he's a
conservative
heard this before it's you know very
very traditional conservative positions
on a lot of issues
aoc is like you know the green new deal
was not even about the environment it
was you know equity for college
and whatever equity equity bills thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you